hello all so basically the new beta has
added a couple new things that are
pretty exciting number one is this is
the first time that we're able to play
The Merchant Alliance and it's also the
first time that the raids the skeleton
raids are live so first things first is
we should always be surveying the the
skies right now for a big skeleton cloud
with glowing green eyes because that
means there's a raid going down I don't
see one
so none yet so let's go ahead and we'll
go to the merchants alliance and we'll
get our first merchants alliance voyage
section first time I'm playing it too
I'm very excited all right cool so
what's up this is hello Mandy the senior
trader
so let's let's check out what her offers
are okay I'm just gonna buy all these
offers cuz they're free thank you dang
it just got dark I don't know we're
still no I can't I can invite John Luke
to the voice chat oh wait no you would
have to I dropped my pirate hat can you
invite John Luke to the ER I set up the
party on that one shoot maybe you can
join the party cuz I don't like a full
screen show your personal info all right
so we're currently trying to purchase a
merchant alliance we're trying to
purchase the merchants alliance voyage
and while we do that we're gonna try to
get John Luke here into the voice chat
party all right cool let's see did I get
them yep I got them
all right friends any luck with John
Luke no oh I can hear you in here now am
i a little quiet for you cuz I'm the one
that's not in this party okay so I can
try to join the party I can't join the
party strange alright let's go ahead and
jump on our boat because it's voyage
time wow it got dark fast alright let's
head into the captains quarters to
propose a voyage alright here we go I'm
going to prose a pressing plea from the
pitiful mr. Wilson alright so first
thing you do is you propose it and then
everyone in your crew has to vote for
the one they want to do although for it
alright ooh this is cool I like this
alright so let's see what the challenge
is the challenges we have to bring back
to the Merchant Alliance by midnight on
the seventh one white feather chicken
and one black plum the chicken that's
interesting because I didn't know there
are multiple chickens so I guess we
should go to the map and see for a near
chicken Island because I know that's a
thing alright so at golden sands outpost
we're looking for chickens
Wow mine is lying out like crazy where
do you guys think chickens might be
should you just try cannon Cove oh my
god let's try cannon Cove it's nearby
it's to the northeast let's do it
alright can you guys can you guys raise
the anchor before you lower the sails
because we can turn the boat oh I'm
lagging a little bit too not too bad
alright so the boys are going to raise
the anchor we want to go towards the
Northeast we're kind of headed in the
right direction already also what's up
chat how's everybody doing
happy Friday happy almost weekend all
right now you guys can go ahead and
lower the sails all right all right yeah
we're pretty much going in the right
direction Hey look get your lanterns out
aurora borealis really yeah this game is
gorgeous
simply gorgeous whoa that's some crazy
lag there it's doing okay now today if
it gets worse then we might have to do
that but it seems to be okay now and
don't forget to it it also right now the
point of these these betas this is now
the first time that rares opened it up
to the public
in previous it's been a closed beta it's
been a closed alpha this is the first
time they're really trying to stress
test the crap out of this game to see
how it's going to handle March 20th when
it releases all right so we're gonna
head over to Cannon Cove now and see if
we can find a couple chickens the only
thing is is that I think we need cages
you guys seen the cages on the ship or
where they're some of the outposts that
we should have grabbed that's equipment
chests and then there's vanity oh I may
have screwed this up we need we need
there's still one more oh cage right
here yeah I don't see a cage all right
someone be my eyes I don't know how
close we are to the island okay
i hi I will say for those of you and
chat who were talking about whether
you're pumped up for the game and
whatnot this is my most anticipated game
of 2018 hands down
1,000% I love this game I think I've
probably put in easily a hundred hours
oh my god a hundred plus between the
technical alpha the closed beta is the
scale tests we got an exciting video
coming out soon where I literally just
talk for eight minutes about how much I
love this game
my excitement lies in Red Dead
Redemption - for this I don't I can't
see so if you guys want to drop the
anchor whenever we get near humne but we
should probably drop the anchor about
now okay drop it somebody drop it is
anyone there
to drop it we're good Oh we'll have to
repair that but somebody drop it oh
there's no one near it
no no one dropped it Robert I'm dropping
it now but I probably shouldn't hop all
right it's fine
I will turn us in a direction so that we
can fire ourselves onto the islands with
cannons can someone go down to the
bottom and repair the holes though so
wood is right here fine we're good wood
is in like the middle so oh boy it's
where's the hole I think Rob repaired it
you repaired it oh he didn't he didn't
all right so let's quickly bail this
water whoever just did that you threw
the water back into the ship Oh lagging
like crazy
sorry about the lag I'm assuming it's
the wood is right here next to the
cannonballs so second floor right by the
stairs at the back
all right don't oh boy okay I just
teleported from the top of the ship to
the bottom yeah that's like a fool right
a bit for me I'm wondering if this is
our internet or it's just their servers
getting stressed out Oh God
oh my gosh this is rough
all right somebody found the hole though
this is rough okay I think I'm good now
no it's getting pretty bad uh Rob are
you lagging at all you're good it's
getting pretty bad for me and Jake so
that's just us in here all right
anyway I'm going to hop onto this cannon
and fire myself onto land see you guys
over there all right so we're looking
for two types of chickens and I think I
also need to find some cages ooh there's
a black chicken here I don't have a cage
and there's a couple of brown chickens
oh god there's another crew here hello
let's dance
hello greasy elk how are you
don't shoot at him don't shoot at him
cuz the Robert don't you shoot at him
give us all you got all right I oh wait
I think I found a cage no is this not a
cage uh I mean it is a cage maybe it's
not one you can pick up oh no oh no
Rob's gonna fight there's a skeleton
behind him save him Rob Rob did all
right so listen I'm currently looking
for let's all dance let's all do we give
him to come with us let's all dance
everyone dance no come back
crazy oh here's his buddy mojito legend
hello this is the most peaceful don't
kill them
how do you dance uh you go down on the
d-pad and then you press up he's leaving
oh all right
okay anyway let's try to help me bail
oh no who's shooting okay all right so I
think I screwed us up I think we need to
get the cages for the chickens at the
always a pig in the water I think we
need to get the cages at the outpost
just we need to go all the way back
well no it's right I picked the islands
closest I'm like look up here really
quick and see if there any cages vendors
have cages you can find some on Islands
says oh the cages are cube-shaped says
oh look it's a brown pig it's a little
hog get over here oh my god I love this
they're just wild animals running around
the island so should we head back yeah I
don't see any Rob kill them
why'd you kill him robb
he was friendly alright let's quickly
run back to an outpost we might have to
get a different voyage because our time
is up
can I shoot the chicken what are you
doing with them
what is Rob doing leave this pig it's
under water
how are you breathing you're not a fish
okay let's go to the boat okay they need
to yes Kubb you did call it Oh God
hello mojito legend see ya I am lagging
like Craig right now I'm gonna kill
mojito
oh no who stood there stealing our ship
alright I'm swimming to our ship if it
would stop lagging oh my god
oh no they're crashing our ship into
short No oh this is a mess Oh No
we thought this friendly creature Luke
is on here oh wait maybe he's not kill
this guy he's being mean I died
come here Keanu Reeves or wherever his
name is oh god he shoot me shot me
pretty good oh that's you gentlemen
hello on god i'm god alright we kill
them hey Rob alright uh do you want to
just scuttle the ship and then we'll
start over yeah let's do that
so let's sink a hoop is right we should
be acting like pirates I shouldn't be
making friends with these people sorry
you're right I mean it doesn't make for
an interesting stream oh shoot he killed
me as I was putting my captain's hat on
yar scurvy alright so I'm now headed to
the ship of the Damned by captain remi
flora hello let's do all he's gone so it
looks like the ship the ship's gone it
sank
damn alright head to the mermaid because
we needed to start off start over anyway
you sure you played this game for hours
yes I am Ben I love this game I love it
via the animal thing hasn't been in any
of them yet nope this is the first and
we one of our complaints the last time
we played it was that the eyes are - you
keep moving away from Mike there - quiet
alright new ship hey let's quickly check
the island here and see if you see any
cages
there's square cages I'll take some
bananas and some cannonballs uh we need
to go to a outpost - an outpost and get
some cages for the chickens wait you
should see a mermaid okay who's behind
Rob what's yes let's uh where's an
outpost let's see how close we are to
one
snake all right cool we need to go down
to plunder outpost which is directly
ahead of us and grab some cages so
someone help me raise this anchor please
no you got it oh yeah who's just what
look at him what's he doing I know
that's Rob yes Carlos says Carlson the
YouTube chat says cages can also be
found on shore I didn't see any there so
I'm assuming that other crew probably
grabbed the most Amara it's alright drop
the sails you lot we're heading right
all right I will guide you mr. Jake
you're gonna go dead straight right to
plunder outpost all right I can't see a
lot because there's Rob in front of me
sail Rob what are you doing oh he's
dancing
wait he's dancing on your spam not my
screen maybe get closer well this game
has quite a lot of kinks to work out
hello John Luke how are you alright so I
see another galleon at the other one
let's say that might have been the
galleon that killed us we can take them
so if you're killed and your ship is
it's still okay you just spawn back on
the ship if you're killed in a sink your
ship you're a new galleon or a new sloop
whatever kind of ship you have we'll go
somewhere else onto the map and then
you'll be spawn there safely you use
like mermaids spawn around we're just
going straight still yep you're going
dead straight there's another galley in
there so we'll have to see what happens
like a storm - yes Rick we know make
sure someone's there to protect the ship
I think there's a little bit of
disorganization as we try to figure out
how the merchants alliance quests work
the game is absolutely gorgeous I agree
with you booster on YouTube the game is
beautiful I said in a recent gallery I
wrote I think it's the most beautiful
video game water I've ever played and
depending on what parts of the seas
you're on the ooh keep an eye out for
those skeleton clowns depending on which
sees you're on because the map is split
into fours get out of my face Robert
what are you doing you turn turns to the
left a little bit turn to the left
slightly in your compass turn to the
left slightly very slightly
Gianluca saying the game looks amazing
on PC right now Robbie's telling us to
look out Liam the point of this game is
to communicate with one another so if
you don't like the communication that's
too bad how can i download this game I'm
pretty sure it's just available in the
market in the Xbox Live Marketplace or
probably on the Xbox PC yep I'm
currently playing on xbox 1x Jake is
also playing on xbox 1x I believe Rob is
playing on xbox 1x nope regular thanks
and then John Lucas playing on PC all
right I'm gonna pull up next to the ship
get ready on the cannons alright
turn us a little bit
to eat are to the right I'll shoot I
pulled it too early all right lift the
anchor a little bit because we just got
to push up a little bit
PC 4k baby says goat man nope this is
the first day of the beta open beta
Lucas yep and 10 a.m. Greenwich Mean
Time on Sunday which is 2 a.m. Pacific
time will someone help me lift this
please oh good work all right are we
next to up it drop it drop it drop it
drop it
no no no chop chop chop chop it nope oh
we goofed no no oh my god I think we I
get turret turn it yes yeah oh maybe too
much oh god we turned too much we turned
all the way around we can't
once the anchors down oh oh they're
coming hello goodbye
I hit him organic beans oh oh he's got a
blunderbuss oh he has a blunderbuss yes
I am doing good they're coming they're
coming to the ship they're coming to the
ship okay underwater sword fight yeah
it's kind of clunky and he's healing
he's hearing no what happened to this
sniper dude I buy that now no he killed
me this sniper you have to but we would
have to buy so these guys have been
playing for a little while because they
have some things unlocked they have the
blunderbuss unlocked yeah this dude
ain't gonna hit me with a blunderbuss
from here though are there any updates
to the fairy of the Damned I don't think
so I think this all looks exactly the
same he should be the same all right so
max levels and stuff so how max levels
work are there two stages that rare has
announced the first stage is called
become pirate legend
so to become a pirate legend you're
gonna want to level up all your factions
oh I got some ones in our ship someone's
inside the ship this is the one issue I
do have with this game is that you can
try to do quests and stuff like that but
if you get overwhelmed by another crew
that can become just a little tedious
which is what's going on but yeah so the
firt oh my god he just spawned killed me
too huh
he just spawned killed me I spawned in
and he shot me in the face all right
this is not showcasing the game very
well damn anyway there's two stages
there's become pirate legend which is
the first stage and the second stage is
becoming a legendary captain to become a
part legend you want to up upgrade and
upgrade an upgrade to all your factions
and then when your factions are all are
they just spawn killing I don't know I
load it in and then I went straight back
to loading Oh yep they're here I think
they're sinking the ship
I hit him and hit him again
John Luke says the hole hit me directly
with a cannonball damn nice loading
screen is long okay are they in here yep
they're in here their spawn killing if I
can kill them them oh you said them so
much Wow are you this is a joke right
okay thank you I killed one
ai ai ai yeah there just lets you gently
lift the anchor lets get out of here
yeah also if I look through my passion
to him alright do that then I'm gonna
sink us anyway
alright go ahead and scuttle the ship if
you want so go so go into your settings
and go to my crew and then hit scuttle
ship and then select yes now I don't
think so I killed one
yeah
all right teamwork
snappy skills someone jumped in I think
there's something over here yes there is
progression there's two end games to
work Tori we're gonna crash into them
yeah turn the wheel so we crashing it
indirectly oh man I want to do some of
the new things but these guys keep
overwhelming I'm on their ship
I'm gonna see how long I can hide out on
their ship No
I need ball any cannonballs and go get
something okay here we go okay
they're on our ship I'm on their ship so
there is a way that you can kill them
from the inside you would need to grab a
a gunpowder barrel you'd bring the gun
power about barrel to the inside and you
would shoot it I'm not getting any sound
and it would explode at all no just like
ambient sounds you need to die
that's what our ships think finally I
hear ie Rob
I will say these loading screens are
what you want what brings you here you
you organic beans yo what's up gaming
Norton Network how's it going I can
patch some holes the only problem is
like reset
get rid of our ship we should just do
that you want to reset do you want to
reset and get a new ship do you want
alright we're sinking let's reset so go
into your menu I know we're fixing the
ship let's sink it's sunk it's son
oh cool behind me in a sinking ship rob
is just walking around here like
everything's fine hello goat man holds
me as we go down together John Luke ah
John Luke John Luke all right where's
that mermaid
no our ship all right let's pick up some
quests and let's do those let's guess
before we drown no John Luke all right
go to the mermaid mines on Robert you
don't hate your crew I think you saved
the other ship I think you were fixing
their ship mean I wasn't fixing you know
Rob Diddy Tampa I love this game
regardless of how the stream is going
this is my favorite game of the year so
far even though it's not good okay we
need to get to an outpost safely and get
cages for chickens that is our main
priority right now and now I'm lagging
okay where aren't we we're on snake
island
those guys are at plunder outpost so is
there any other outposts we can go to
ancient spire outpost it's to our East
so let's go to any language outpost
yeah just cancel it because we're going
to start another one so let's go ahead
and lift the anchor I'll hop on the
wheel Shawn Luke just fell from the sky
what just fell from the sky in front of
me he's here now
goodbye goob good to see you in the
twitch chat see you around man someone's
gonna okay I'm gonna go help you okay
excuse me all right slower the sales
where are we going we're heading east I
will guide you as soon as I get these
sales to the outpost with two boats by
it is there really I don't think we can
see it now oh no no that that's the
skeleton fort okay
also it's keep an eye out for the
skeleton forts maybe we'll get a little
raid action because that will be very
combat oriented so keep turning turning
turning turning turning turning right to
the right to the right we're gonna go
right by crooks Hollow and then we're
gonna keep going down to ancient spire
out how big is the map says Robert Cole
let me show you so ancient aisles are in
this corner this is up in us a full map
though right this is the beta map we're
not sure we're not sure the shore of
plenty is up in the top left the wilds
is down or no it's in the top oh no top
right and then top and the bottom right
is ancient Isles
oh shoot I should be guiding you all
right now straighten it out
I am straightening up perfect but it's
not straightening turn a little bit to
the left you want to kind of like cut
right by that you see the UM the spires
in the background there Jake that is
where you want to go I will turn your
sails so whose music is it Rob yes
oh wait here I'll uh I'll play the other
instrument let's do it oh not that song
this one this one now play your
hurdy-gurdy
he just wants to dance let him dance are
you dancing for me yeah
and you look good man yeah chuckling why
are you wearing oh it's a woman you're
allowed
all right so turn to the right a little
bit terms the right terms right I'm
doing okay actually as a man I'm gonna
go put a dress on I can put a dress on
you go down here to the hull and you go
over to here to the vanity chest and you
can put on a vanity chest is like beards
and stuff so I'm gonna give my guy a
moustache and then I'm gonna give myself
a I don't have any of these so go to the
gear chest where's that oh here it is
here's the clothing chest I'm gonna I'm
gonna take all my clothes off I'm uh I'm
gonna take that dress up no no I want to
take the dress off I'll take my pants
off - I think I'm a lady with a mustache
I'm a lady with a must and I shall go
into these alright let me take a look
let's see if we see anyone look at that
sunrise I think we need to be between
these two office showing what time is it
Rob yeah keep going
okay we need to get between these two
rocks or you can go around I'm Jake
whatever you choose if you're gonna go
through them you're gonna have to turn
to the right hard I think we're gonna
hit the do you absolutely need friends
to play this game says Reggie no you
don't all right now quickly turn to the
other way turn to the left
hard hard hard our our turn our turn our
Oh Jake threatened what Rob I can you
show me your compass can you show me
your compass where are you oh thank you
fall are you fell over now being able um
just makes me think use a childlike look
at what I have all right so this is
where we want to go whoa are you digging
now all the different things that you
can do all right get ready to drop the
anchor I'll do it I'll do it
turn to the left a little bit you got it
boss
all righty I'm Lauren Ben things need to
sink our boat easy
oh yeah Ben I like to see you try all
right so everybody let's go to shore and
we need to find cages for chickens in
pigs and little snakes declarant what
he's doing I'm digging oh sure you could
say that the game is all about cosmetic
items but honestly it's about me just
being a pirate with my friends it's all
I care about man is just being a pirate
with my friends all right so let's see
we need to find some cages whoa you guys
shoot yourself hello Merchant Alliance
oh I see a cage out in the water I'm
gonna go get it okay okay I have one
cage see if you guys can find some other
ones ask actually talk to the merchant
Ally and see if you can buy them whoa
chicken coop all right so I got a
chicken coop collect chicken coop hey
that's how we do it all right
Robin John Luke if you can still hear me
can you guys grab a chicken coop
Rob's probably up in the tavern drinking
what time is it just know how long we've
been going okay I want to at least
finish one one quest before also for
those of you guys have been playing it
looks like the gold hoarders is still
alive so you can play both the gold
hoarders quests and the merchants
Alliance which is awesome so if you go
to the merchants alliance the lady that
gave us the quest earlier you can ask
her for a coop you yes ms field you can
cross play the beta between PC and Xbox
right now we are playing on xbox one X's
and John Luke who is where are you John
Luke are you behind me he's somewhere he
might be on our ship he is playing on
his PC in 410 God look at how beautiful
this game is all right I'm back on the
boat with this coop on in the captain
quarters and my quarters she's on the
dock hmm she on the dock she's gonna
look very snooty where's our other
fellow mates
yeah we're gentle look where are you the
Galilean over there
oh no that's a single sailed sloop if
you guys have any questions about the
game please feel free to ask I obsess
over this game so Oh so you can only
have three all right so let's I'm gonna
propose a voyage Jake
come down here oh no we oh yeah I'm
gonna cancel this while you have this
look at this guy look at this guy is
that robbers that John that's Rob he
swim faster
yes I mean so slow oh my god look at
this guy all right I need Rob and John
Luke to propose to cancel our current
voyage and start the next one I'm gonna
quickly go and turn the wheel just so we
had in a non island direction go ahead
and put the cage inside the captains
quarters
and then vote to cancel the current
voyage Oh we'll start the next one all
right come in here all right go ahead
and vote to cancel that all right now I
will propose the next one the poll a
polite contract from the pitiful mrs.
Tarrant so I will propose that voyage
we'll vote and now we're prepared
because we have the things we need
rocking heads wants to know can you see
other players online yes you can yeah
you missed us give him a reef to buy a
couple of them all right so go ahead and
vote again Rob's just holding a banana
John Luke and Rob vote please he's
eating a banana you to vote hey
according to Rob we have plenty of
bananas Robert there we go all right so
the contract reads by midday on the 8th
we need one feathered chicken in one red
speckled chicken to plunder outpost so
let's see where we are now I don't think
this is plunder outpost so we are not a
plunder outpost plunder outpost is over
there so the first thing we need to do
is let's head over to crow's nest
fortress and let's find some chickens
all right I'm on the wheel oh sorry
Gianluca sounds like he's away Rob Rob's
gonna be on the wheel all right someone
help me raise this anchor no you got it
we are going to the nearest island so
the island off to your right hand side
you should see it can you see it I will
give you a warden 40 mike says I've
already sunk a lot of hours into this
game you and uh you and forty Mike
should exchange info yeah dude forty
Mike you're gonna you can sink another
404 D money you see that uh that one's
the release date March March twenty
years
March 20th okay March the 20th believe
March 23rd is far cry southwest well
South by Southwest
alright straighten this out straighten
this out yeah there are just so many
things that I am excited for with this
game especially the raid system which is
apparently active what is he laughing at
especially the river yeah let me show
you guys what these two are doing hey
Rob do have a timeout for this one we do
have a time limit we do have a time of
it Island is it is this the time Rob
alright so what's our time limit our
time limit is that we need to have these
two chickens when I try to outpost on
the 8th are we going to Devil's Ridge
yes we're going to Devil's Ridge I mean
I'm hoping there's chickens there
there's a small little island there we
gotta be careful of who's drunk John
Luke is drunk
John Luke are you drunk good work John
Luke he's drunk careful there's a small
island to the right in front of us
alright shai pull the anchor either pull
the anchor Rob needs a turn pulling it
all right so we need coke man says I'm
so drunk
we need one white feathered chicken and
one red speckled chicken so let's go
find some chickens loading the cage
shoot get the get the get the cages load
in the can and I'll shoot you guys we'll
get the cages get the cages yeah I know
loading the cannon I'll shoot you guys I
don't think you should go in the cage
that with the cage into the cannon that
would be stupid if you can't all right
Rob this cannon over by me Rob oh you
can't
great all right all right bring the
coops to shore we only need two coops
though
oh well then all launch over there I'll
see if I can hunt them down yeah oh look
at that beautiful shot by me
John Luke do you see chickens Rob ask
John Luke if he sees chickens seem
chickens no no chickens okay I don't
know how you catch them I think he's
smack them with the cage I bet oh I see
a pig I wonder if I can shoot it and got
it
what what's that Rob oh I shot the pig I
hit the pig can I kill the pig oh I I
don't know oh so we could see the chat I
I don't know if there's a preset and I
don't want to start just messing with it
mess it up I like a tin funny sharks
here yeah I'm surprised they haven't
seen any sharks I'm certainly not
complaining there's a guy here no
there's not oh it's John Luke always
opens
okay I need to find some chickens
anyone seen any chickens I'm looking
chickens here's a piggy I'm gonna see if
I can catch this piggy this one this one
stuck oh wait what's this is a chicken
or is that a pig that's big Hey lots of
skeletons oh I don't know if you can
check you can catch the pigs yet you can
download it right now on Xbox Live
Marketplace or on the xbox pc
marketplace I'm not entirely sure what
that's called dude on the left your loud
yawn our boat it's not there is another
boat here no at least I think oh wait no
maybe that is our boat guys I'm not
seeing chickens on this on I think we
might have to go somewhere else you're
looking at Xbox one gameplay there's got
to be chickens on this island I ain't
going back no we'll just go to the next
Island I ain't going back without
chickens I don't see any chickens yeah
nevermind that is our boat we're good
can we bring them pigs
yeah no chickens here dang
[Music]
did you go all the way up here what
should go up here yeah I didn't seen
chickens can other players come to
sabotage your mission yes they can it's
pretty annoying
all right everyone come back to the boat
there's actually a cannon on the
shoreline that's if you want to shoot
yourself back onto the boat yeah I'm
just carrying this the coop say you know
did someone just Rob do you shoot
yourself out of a cannon maybe the
skeletons on the cannon not for long
all right we what time is it we got a
couple days but we need to work on this
we need to find these chickens all right
took a bit of damage but I've got let's
try to go to thieves haven I think I
broke my leg Nick
you broke your are you walking funky
yeah yeah you broke it like it'll it'll
fix in a second don't worry yeah we're
all here go man says don't know you guys
can use the mermaid to catch up Rob and
I are out of here
so you guys where's that stupid cannon
[Laughter]
I'm looking for the stupid cannon I
decide I can't find it now so you can't
find the cannon on guess doesn't matter
now cuz my to use up no Jake used the
mermaid oh I found the cannon yeah but
that's not as much fun alright see you
can catch us I'll turn I'll turn towards
you no there's no way I don't think I
can turn towards you see we do this I'm
so happy too I love this game this game
makes me oh good he almost made it
alright someone pull the anchor pull the
anchor okay
let's see where is he where is he you
know what game is this all right so I'm
thinking so what time is it
cuz we have a couple days to do this Rob
Rob's got a clock a watch Rob show show
me your watch Rob look look at how many
what time it is I don't know why that's
so funny
alright let's go find some chickens
we're getting some insider info one odd
gamer says hey chickens are on smugglers
Bay and shipwreck Bay how abouts thieves
Haven you think there any chickens there
let's try let's try it so we need to
turn around and go west
alright I'm on the wheel alright I'm
going to lift the anchor someone help me
out what is this guy doing get off there
and help me
oh he's gonna stand watch Oh Robert you
know that makes me do all the work
all right we're going we're moving okay
guys we have until the 8th it is almost
the 3rd hey Rob where are you come here
come here
give me your lantern give me your
Lantern open your Lantern we're on a
tight deadline here you see we're on a
deadline let's go make them walk the
plank
all right let me guide you
uh-oh we got a crow's nest fortress oh
no it's a fortress fortress and let me
in there just keep turning keep come on
Nick I thought you played this turn it
hard turn it hard turn it hard too hard
you said West Bend the game is not $100
I don't know where you got that
information but it's faulty it is $60
also quick note and a good note for
those of you who are Xbox game past
members this game is part of Xbox game
pass and it is it will come day one on
Xbox game paths if you already have it
you can play see if thieves day 1 boom
yep Meiko soldier just just confirmed it
all right so pass the fortress
what will pass in the fortress I can
kind of talk to you guys about what's
going on here with the update so
basically what's going on is they've
added a raid system and so the oh in
Australia okay that makes sense that
makes sense
so these fortresses are filled to the
brim with skeletons from
teutonic but it's all their only active
when there's a giant skull cloud above
it with glowing green eyes so when the
scope cloud is there that means that the
raid is active so that means all crews
can see the raid you guys will kind of
converge on the island and you'll fight
through waves of enemy pirates when you
defeat the captain the captain will drop
a key and the key well let's go straight
that I that little island might have
some chickens so the captain will drop a
key to the fort's vault and inside the
vault there'll be a ton of treasure and
so that's kind of the raid content so
far on stream though we've been playing
for an hour now a little less than an
hour we we have not seen any of those
skill clouds so it's a it's an emergent
gameplay system so don't know don't know
if we'll see one if we do we do in the
next 30 minutes if we don't we don't we
will finish this this merchant Alliance
challenge someone dropped the anchor I'm
a drunk
alright I'm gonna quickly go swim to
that Island and I'm gonna check to see
if they're chickens you guys stay on the
boat
I'll tell you to bring the coops if we
need it quickly swim on the island huh
let's keep the chat respectful guys
let's not gang up on one another we are
all friendly pirates here on the open
ocean I'm not a friendly pirate it is
pretty funny that I was telling Jake I
was playing the scale test this weekend
and I was sailing a single sailed sloop
and these two guys came up to me and
they were like hey we're a friendly ship
but I had a lot of treasure on my boat
and I didn't want to risk it so I killed
them both and I sank their ship but it's
kind of ironic because I've been looking
for like friendly sailors for who knows
how long GUP says I'm with Jake I'm a
I'm a mean so there are no friendly
pirates let's play some music says Rob
alright there are skeletons here not
looking like there's chickens
there's some skeletons here no chickens
let's go
no chat here alright lift the anchor
I'll swim out to you guys and I'll catch
you while you're moving actually I'll
take the mermaid here get going then
we'll get going yep get going I can meet
you hello help me raise the anchor sure
help Jake raise the anchor Rob's helping
I think she's on looks getting on be
nice in the chat nice to one another all
right
[ __ ] go to what Islander be near
thieves Haven that's a big island and
we're going straight towards it sick be
as plunder outpost is there so we now
have how many days left to find we have
Rob five days left
really guys smugglers Bay is a ton of
chickens oh we hit a rock smugglers
Bay's a little far away though
yeah smugglers Bay is very fun you gonna
help repair yes yes yes Suzy did just
the one hole well I hit it pretty hard
is it this big rock thing yeah it should
be a famous agreed smugglers has them
for sure all right so let's go to
smugglers where is it
no no no turn uh turn to the left no
right right
Yeah right where we going Peace Haven
yes
Smuggler's check check Mountaineer Rock
use your telescope let's see oh wait no
I was just there I was just there
unless you guys want to go we can take
everyone suggestions and we can go to
chicken Highland let's go to chicken
island we're all right here we're almost
here
I was just say okay yeah we're almost
here well check these Haven if not we'll
go straight to chicken island
you cannot crouch
alright let's kind of swing around to
the other side of the island with the
beat cheese I wish I could rock the boat
and make Rob fall off hello Rob
[Music]
says I see a pirate
[Music]
turn to the right
mmm but yeah guys being a lookout for a
feature about 10 things to be excited
for and see of Thieves
I finished it last night we're working
on getting it through some just checking
to make sure everything looks good on it
making some last-second changes and then
be sure to check that out that'll be on
gamespot.com GameSpot's youtube channel
does anyone see all right I'm looking on
the island for chickens you may not oh
wait chickens bunch of chickens bunch of
chickens someone so I'll drop in a good
anchor pull the anchor bunch of chickens
bunch of chickens
we know put those chickens are right
there all right you guys repair the ship
I'm going to get some chickens all right
what kind of chickens do I need a red
speckled chicken that's a red speckle
chicken cross I could find out come here
what do i what button my press or oh you
have to hold it hey I got a chicken no I
Colin it says my name Collin oh you did
wait I want to look at it guys
I am so hungry now chicken for chicken
when you get another one don't we so
does booster booster the chances now I
feel like eating chickens meat - dude
what what what other one what other type
do we need we need a white one we need a
white chicken what do you have I have a
red speckled oh wait it's freaking out
do I have to feed it I don't know I
here do you want the banana oh I hate
the banana do you want this banana I
don't think you feed it I think you feed
the pigs all the chickens are gone Nick
I scared them I see one I see one he's
over here oh oh wait those aren't white
though right well it's got to be a white
one somewhere around here if not we're
good now we have plenty of time also be
on the lookout for random treasures this
this particular island is always
notorious for just having rando
treasures you're sitting around and if
we find them we can only just sell them
to the the gold hoarders I'll think
about it I don't think they're gonna be
any around here they're gonna be on the
shoreline let's go to chicken island we
got one here go to chicken okay make
sure we don't go over I know those of
you guys who are looking for the are you
shooting the chickens Rob oh I heard you
shooting that I heard oh wait what was
that wait is this a white chicken right
here I don't know I don't think so
yeah I think it's a speckled chicken Oh
Pig don't eat a pig though oh look more
coops here's some somebody come grab
these coops with me
all right let's go to chicken island and
then we'll go to plunder outpost after
oh I like this red chicken can we keep
this red chicken I caught one I don't
think you can catch the pigs yet also
the pigs are glitching out bad all right
back to the ship
oh wait white chickens right here dear
white chickens right there where across
the water okay I'm smelly I see it oh no
oh no they're a boat just sink our boat
you sunk
how did think was there a hole that we
didn't catch up haha no that chickens
gonna drown I got this one the chickens
gonna drown how did our boat sink oh no
[Music]
poor chicken we're gonna have to catch
the chickens again huh
[Music]
why did our boat sink oh wait no the
chickens still here yeah but we can't
bring the chicken with us just the cage
hit the chicken before chicken is just
gonna drown no well lose the chicken
coop the poor chicken is dead before
chicken died
I bet robbing something dude oh no Rob
says hell no wow get a new ship oh when
you die you just get one or not when you
die when your ship sinks you'll just
spawn on new island with one are we near
chicken island at least I don't know if
you have coops though now know what the
clock is right are we out of coops now
Oh No yeah you had the surrender and
when you know two people should have
stayed there you know with the with the
coops and the chickens oh that would
have been smart
two people stayed and then you guys
respond back on the boat and yeah well
how close are we to chicken island it's
right there and plunder outpost is right
behind us we quickly turn around grab
some and go over there but it still
could take a little while let's try
we'll play for another 15 minutes or so
alright damn
that makes me sad
more so that we killed those chickens
will find more it's not like you named
them I know I was gonna I think Rob's
right it was the chicken he sank it
didn't it was the chicken that we left
on boat alone that sank it so the
chickens they were bad chickens so the
chickens are sirens Lauren sailors to
their doom all right we need to go we
need to turn completely around to
plunder outpost it should be right there
where is it we need to turn around
completely yeah all right we'll drop the
sale
we'll keep turning until we drop this
out okay Rob says F kg chicken called
KFC see now now Ben's being nice in a
chat so we plunder in coast to coast
yeah I got to go to plunder outpost cuz
we need um we need it's right there it's
the tall one I'm straightening we need
we need coops again when are we going to
get a skeleton raid I don't know keep
turning that's thieves Haven so keep
turning plunder out pusses to your right
yeah we are definitely getting chicken
sandwiches for lunch Tay says winter
when are we getting a raid oh I have not
seen a raid so far and it's popped up
Rashad shared and says hey guys what's
up what up thanks for stopping by
hello mr. four oh my god is it this it's
the tall one okay yes
Finn pom says why don't you go back
thieves haven their work oops there I
picked him up and I'm looking in the
water Brian let's know if we can name
animals yeah sure I can name Jake you're
in our name you're in charge of naming
so who all Damon I'll keep them on
lockdown make sure they don't ship look
our boat again what was the name of the
red one that that sunk our ship
Terrance probably chickens with human
names I love it
definitely Terrance all right so here's
what's gonna happen two of us are gonna
go to the shore I am lagging like crazy
two of us are gonna go to the shore and
get two coops and then this one this one
two of us are you got to go rob okay
Rob's out of here
goodbye Robert all right so two of us
are going to jump off grab the coops I'm
not even going to stop okay I'm not even
gonna when I meet the right anchor
you're gonna have to nope cuz we can't
use the mermaids to spawn to you I want
to plunder Skelly for it but none of the
scaly forts are active you have to there
has to be a cloud above them and the
clouds don't look I don't see any I
don't see any what's my call it's
diamond dice wants to know also can Xbox
and PC play together yep goatman 42 is
actually playing on PC right now
jean-luc is a plane on the PC turn us to
the right a little bit our left left
yeah big X I'm looking for skull clouds
but none of the forts have been active
and we played for about an hour and a
half I know after this I'll be going
back to my desk to eat chicken
sandwiches and play this game so I will
try to see today not active all right
I'm gonna drop the anchor and then all
go with John Luke so short and we'll
grab two poops yeah
it's eat it later
alright it's John Luke with me or gays
behind you
okay I'm lagging a little bit we will
who whoo
excuse me ma'am may I have a chicken
coop god this game is freaking beautiful
look at that I'm a playful cat my desk
I'm excited
what is the third trading company says
Oliver the three trading companies are
the gold hoarders which are treasure
which is x marks the spot in riddles
this second is the merchants Alliance
which is the one we are playing right
now which is going out and getting
resources and bringing them back on time
and then the third one is the order of
souls the order of souls challenges you
to like go out and get we need to go to
the north now go out and get right
though go out and get what the heck you
have to kill like pirates pirate
skeletons and collect their souls and
bring them back so those three there are
more though rarest clearly stated there
are other ones whether those will be at
launch or those will be post launch
updates I'm not sure I guess we'll find
out oh no I see another galleon
now we can go straight go straight
straight to chicken and hopefully that
galleon is not going to chicken island
as well they are not
anybody that wants to Joe turn to left
turn to left
alright strain now it I liked it more
when this one always meant center of the
gold one
it does it does just on center and it I
was on the gold one it if you if you
like turn really hard it'll continue to
it'll take a little while to like set
itself so I always like turned really
hard alright so chicken island is off to
our left there it's a little one how do
you find chicken on so to find chicken
island you go down to the map here this
is a xbox exclusive but it's a Microsoft
exclusive which means it's on PCs so
technically it's not an X it's not an
Xbox exclusive but it still is it's not
gonna be on places so turn us to the
left to the west yeah turn hard turn
hard as hard as you can because we're
headed towards snake island
we're not leaking are we okay now I am
lagging like crazy are you - yeah yeah
oh I'm just spawning all over the map
yeah sorry guys this will not be coming
to PlayStation and I don't think it will
be coming at all we need to cut keep
cutting hard left
right yep left left is that snake island
we don't want to go into those rocks and
we want to go to that little one right
there the release date March 20th
straighten out
uh yeah yeah cuz I figured the turn will
be good okay cool
now straight ish you still go to the
right through the left a little bit here
and there
no John Smith it is not time to go
attack another ship we are here to serve
the merchants alliance perfect Oliver
MooMoo
I found the merchants Alliance to be
boring he's impossible to find the
chickens we found the chickens but we
suck oh [ __ ] alright turn to the right a
little bit if you can actually turn it
all the way to the right and then we'll
coast in I swear though if these
chickens are not on chicken island
you're going to be very upset and if
they're not there we're ending the
stream ok pulling anchor
all right to the island you bring in a
coupe yep just in case did John Luke
grab the other Cooper no I don't think
so
okay my dear God I don't see any
chickens chicken island is a lie there's
no way it's called chicken island there
are no chickens oh there are chickens
it's just dark there's a red one here
red one here
Oh God using it I have a red one that
I'm chasing but I don't have a coop so
come to me whenever so we need a red in
a white one
yep where the red window can't see that
well it rain into the water can't find
it
tell John Luke to take out as a lantern
so I can see John Luke grab your lantern
oh wait
here's the white one really yeah yeah
they're both here then here yes here is
the whites go get the other coupe
yeah okay I'll quit go get it so prairie
chicken hug yay we're gonna finish this
quest on stream unless our boat sinks at
least one productive stream Mako soldier
was right chicken island has chickens
you right dog you right I was trying to
tell Nick that two before the stream
didn't believe me
yeah I think you can you still run into
solo players if you're to crew I feel
like it doesn't happen that often though
at least yeah so you can group you can
group up people can be a little bit of
bullies online I've been bullied a
little bit in terms of and when I say
bullied I mean a gang of four will just
spawn camp me and they'll kill me as a
single sailor over and over and over
again which can be really really
annoying I'm trying to figure out what
rare is going to do to combat that kind
of that sort of thing I mean I think the
point is that the smaller ones quicker
so you can get away yeah but it's tough
when you get spawn killed that's true
yeah
oh my god I can't even get down here
it's lagging so much I need someone to
help me with light I can't leave this
area
it just keeps lagging I can hear the
chickens but I can't tell which one they
are oh there he is where'd he go
I can hear him I can't see him oh oh oh
here we go goat man's here
alright let's find a red one oh there it
is there it is where'd he go where to go
this Islands tough because where did
that chicken go I in here but I can't
see it oh I got him all right we got the
chickens I think John Luke come over is
this the right one oh it looks red red
speckled chicken and we have a white one
white feathered chicken yes check our
inventory oh god there's a shark shark
shark shark shark shark shark ooh a bit
the shark thinks the chicken would be
Oh lagging a lot well why can't come on
okay go underwater the chicken can't
breathe sorry you can go in order for
quite a while before it Oh God I'm
getting attacked by another shark Oh No
I'm dead were you a chicken to the water
someone get the chicken there's two
sharks but oh no oh no this game is
ruthless sometimes left me in the gods
Oh John Oh John we got the chicken oh
thank god
John Luke um if you guys are struggling
to find people to play with the forum on
Xbox Live is actually really awesome I
could play with a ton of my friends but
I couldn't play with a ton of my friends
and so I would put wow that spawn time
was really quick all right we need to go
back to Jesus that was lag city we need
to go back to plunder outposts turn
around turn around I'm gonna lift the
sails so that we can turn around because
if you if the files are up you can do a
full 360 without them
oh there's boats all right close yeah
pretty close
oh don't ruin this for me
Oh another going another way they're
going a different way
save the chickens okay oh my god the lag
is bad right now
oh he grazed it okay I felt a little
rumble in my controller little rumble
all right only one sales up so we can
now turn around pretty easily let me
tell you when you've turned around
sorry chat about the lag it is atrocious
right now I think it's our Internet it's
not the game turn turn turn
keep bone turn in
turn keep turning that island right
there right I think so all right because
we know this thing turns like crazy you
could probably start turning to the
other straightening it out now all right
cool
all right we just need to avoid this
rock here
Oh Rando joined hey cable games what's
up my dude let's dance
where'd he go what were you doing he's
gonna throw the chickens overboard I
swear to God
let me show him what we're doing this is
all we're doing dude cable see he's got
a he's got one of the new snipers
unlocked or he doesn't I add a little
snide unlock anywho right right right
just turned hard right
we shouldn't be no gaming the game is
not a mess we are a mess and also don't
forget don't forget rare has made it
abundantly clear these betas are meant
to overwhelm their servers break the
game create utter chaos for like the
devs so that they can make sure that
come mate March 20th I don't know why
Syd may March 20th they'll be ready to
go everything will be set so there's
gonna be problems I'm assuming tomorrow
which is a Saturday it's gonna be it's
gonna be a mess the servers are gonna
shut down they're gonna lock it they're
gonna lock players out all righty
[Music]
and don't forget gamespot.com
GameSpot's youtubes games bots twitch
everyday erekt a typically live streams
with somebody around 11 a.m. Pacific
2 p.m. Eastern so hit subscribe on
youtube hit follow on Twitch Tercel
right and you'll be notified when we go
live
is there character creation no there's
not
rare has created the infinite pirate
generator it'll be in that feature
that's coming on gamespot live very soon
they're basically they've guaranteed
that no two pirates will look alike by
using this infinite pirate generator so
what you'll do is you'll cycle through
eight pirates over and over and over
again until you find a pirate you're
interested in then that pirate will
become your pirate for the remainder of
the game we are playing on xbox one X
alright get ready to drop the anchor
closer yeah you should I'm gonna go get
a chicken come here red speckled chicken
and let's complete our first merchant
Alliance faction trade company challenge
to complete the stream 5 minutes late oh
god the chicken can't breathe I'm sorry
I'm sorry I can breathe for quite a
while this is animal cruelty
all righty we did it guys
it took us an hour and a half but we did
it completed one be completed one here
we go
hello ma'am deliver chicken coop oh I
was worth a lot of money for just
seventeen for that one chicken that's a
lot for the one chicken or for the quest
for the one chicken and then the other
chicken was oh we level up to nice
alright alright I'm gonna do some
dancing and then good job just joined us
we're gonna leave I'm sorry poor fella
we gotta go guys thank you all for
joining us
my thanks to Jake for dealing with all
the hiccups I had a good time regardless
of how janky this game is yeah next time
we're stream it we'll probably out yeah
next let me steer and probably be out
I'm excited x10 we streamed this game
not next stream yeah glad you guys took
the time to hang out glad you guys
enjoyed it for more on the game check
out games.com we have a gallery about
ten reasons to be excited there'll be a
video version coming up shortly maybe
Saturday Sunday something like that
stay tuned for Monster Hunter with John
Luke and Ben mm-hmm a little later maybe
like 2 p.m. Pacific so yeah thank you
guys
what button do I hit here to get us out
yeah there's not and what what numbers
are we for audio 140 say goodbye alright
guys thank you for joining us we'll see
you guys next time it's a pirate's life
for everyone